This idea is called the Mixnet. It was invented by
David Chaum. Any you’ll notice that this is quite
similar to onion routing and in fact onion
routing was based on this idea. There is a couple
issues we have to work out though. This kind of
encryption won't work very well. There are some
big problems with the way we’ve described
it so far. So supposed that we do this and we
encrypt this way, how well would this actually
work? If we encrypt to vote as described where
you’re going to use the layered public key
encryption and the vote is the name of the
party, the voter wants to vote for and you can
assume that the encryption is done using RSA
where the public keys are well-known to everyone,
the private keys are kept secret to their correct
owners. And there are no vulnerabilities in RSA.